[Musique]
ça sert à redonner des sensations de la
verticalisation et de la marche de façon
écologique parce que pour la plupart des
patients on les met dans des choses très
statiques avec des appuis partout or là
c'est une façon plus ludique d'être
verticalisée pour ceux qui ne peuvent
pas marcher et c'est une façon de
remarcher alors qu'on n'a pas les
capacités de le faire
[Musique]
ils savent que cet outil n'est pas fait
pour remarcher on leur donne bien les
objectifs de l'utilisation de
l'exosquelette c'est clairement pas un
outil qui fait remarcher quand on a
aucune commande c'est une outil de
compensation donc c'est vraiment de la
réadaptation
[Musique]
donc le fait d'être dans l'exosquelette
autoéquilibré j'ai pas préoccupé du bas
du corps déjà et on peut du coup
travailler avec le haut du corps
travailler le tronc les membres
supérieurs en faisant du tennis en
faisant une basket il y a plein
d'activités très ludiques
[Musique]